rénovation transparence démocratie les
mots sont les mêmes mais il s'agit de la
chine ils sont des milliers à les criées
ces mots depuis trois jours ils sont
massés cette nuit devant le siège du
parti communiste et du gouvernement
chinois patricia cost ils ont attendu sa
mort pour le célébrer le regrette et
ruia aux banques en noir et blanc sur ce
portrait géant par les étudiants en
beaux arts de pékin a déclenché les plus
grandes manifestations que la chine ait
connu depuis la mort de schwann lie
proulx yaobang pourtant n'avait pas
l'envergure de schwann lie loin s'en
faut il n'était même pas tellement
respecté son vivant mais il s'était fait
remarquer par un libéralisme nettement
plus marqué que celui des autres
dirigeants est significatif de l'esprit
des étudiants chinois ce slogan nous ne
voulons plus de grands hommes mais de
vrais hommes et cette revendication est
soutenu depuis trois jours parti à 15000
personnes sans intervention notable de
la police ce qui laisse supposer un
accord tacite de certains des dirigeants
au pouvoir mais si ce mouvement devait
se poursuivre ce serait la cohésion même
de la direction chinoise qui serait
menacée